today we are going to talk about
duplicate ad detection in an online
classified service in Iran
so I'm dear muhammadi I'm a data
scientist in divar which is as I said a
classified uh online ad service in Iran
I've been working in divar for two years
and I've almost finished my bachelor's
degree in computer engineering at the
University of Tehran
uh first of all let's talk about you
know the subject we want to detect
duplicate ads in the Ur So first we want
to know what an ad is
so uh this is
yeah typically an ad on DVR we have a
title here
and it's shown in the listing excuse me
it's in Persian but you know
the fields are important for us not the
text we have a description here which is
more uh descriptive of the descriptive
about the ad we have some fields for
example there are optional for users but
they vary on the category so if you want
to post an car ad it will be completely
different fields and if you want to post
another thing no it will be again
completely different
fields and they are completely optional
we have some images for this ad which
are pretty important and usually each ad
is something something to do with three
images so we have you know a lot of
images to work on
we have this category here which shows
which category the post has been
submitted and the location which is the
for example Tehran or another place that
the ad has been posted so the duplicate
ads uh there are two ways to look for
duplicated ads we can look them in a
global way among all ads and usually
this kind of duplicated ads are done by
spammers uh their intention is to get
more views or sometimes get uh sometimes
it's a local competitions for example
the furniture workshops in a small City
in Iran
they were spamming their own City their
own cities diver for like you know
hundreds of ads per day and it was a
completely and it was a war between them
who can concur the US first page in that
City and it was really amazing for us
that they
they pay so they pay uh money to so many
services at third party services that
can publish publish ads for them and
sometimes this uh
uh somehow third-party apps or services
use text to text translations so they
can skip our detection mechanisms and
somehow they are really stronger than us
you know that's really interesting for
us and
it another important interesting thing
is that they find complicated bugs in
our systems sometimes ancient real
ancient bugs now we have we have a
system we have a service which was you
know developed like nine years or nine
years ago and recently we found out that
it has a bug and they are using it to
publish a tons of posts in the war
uh we are not going to talk about global
duplicates right now because uh you know
it's a really
how to say
a large area to talk about but we are
going to talk about local duplicates
local duplicates is about among users
ads you know so I I post an ad and again
I want to post another ad and if they
are similar we don't uh from you or we
don't want them to be posted they have a
few intentions to do this you know there
are some reasons to do this first of all
is they want to get more views you know
you post your ad it goes down the
listing and no it gets less to view so
we want to get more View and you you
know they want to get more view they
post it again and it gets rejected
also we have some kind of fees to repost
the ad and they want to avoid that so
there's another reason and then we have
these temperatures and really sometimes
they don't know that it's not okay to
First similar ads
so let's talk about some numbers from uh
viewer right now we have 20 million
active users in Iran uh it's like the
grid you know yeah it's the how to say
most used classified accessories in
neuron and there are like half a million
submitted ads each day and we have 120
million unique views per day for ads and
it's a really how to say huge market for
us and we have a team of like 500
operation people working on ads and are
looking for uh fraud ads looking for
spam ads looking for duplicate ads and
we cannot really control it using
operation so that's the reason we are
trying to you know do some sorts of it
with operation and machine learning so
let's talk about a duplicate definition
our operation refers to ads as duplicate
if they are referring to the same Real
World Service or entity now for example
you want to sell this laptop and that's
it you know if if I can if I can
recognize that this uh laptop isn't too
ads we will reject the second one and
that's a little bit in the different for
the global one so because we have a lot
of this kind of laptops so we cannot
reject all laptops in global but we can
reject the same entity among users
uh at
there are some you know tricky points
about it for example avoid or field May
determine that the two ads are not
similar you know I can show you right
now uh these two ads are pretty similar
you know it's in Persian again so sorry
but it's completely similar the only
difference is this number here which is
3500 and which is here 5500 and they are
okay so you know we want a method that
can recognize that can detect that these
two ads are not similar and also we have
other people that
publish the same ad using only changing
some words you know maybe change a
number which are uh duplicate so it's
not that easy to you know get exact
matches or do things like that again
avoid usually named entity mostly May
determine that two ads are similar for
example
uh there's an ad about a horse and the
horse has a name yeah so this guy
attacks and says for example my horse
Zach for example does a real name for
hers uh Zach is pretty good he's pretty
smart and stuff like that and again
another ad which is only attacking in a
word about Zach and we should know that
you know in operation we reject the
second one because it's talking about
the same entity in the real world
and also we you know our operation uh
finds uh similar objects into in the
images and they do reject the second you
know duplicate the second post based on
the images
so let's talk about the problem no State
the problem
we want to predict the similarity of two
ads you know given to us we want to
predict the similarity of them so it's
about basically binary classification
problems not
that complicated and positive class is
duplicate ads so if we predict one we
mean that
these two ads are similar
we used two metrics first of all we use
rcauc which is somehow independent from
threshold when uh you know it gives us a
systemic view generally view that how
will our our model is doing regardless
of the threshold that we set and usually
we compare our models using that metric
also we have another metric which is
more business related recall positive
agricult negative I want to elaborate a
little bit on that uh as we said
positive is the duplicate class for us
and negative is the healthy normal ads
so we want a given recall negative we
want for example 19 19 799 based on the
categories uh negative recall and we
want to know how much recolor positive
we can get if we want to how to stay
stick to that constraint yeah so this
constraints comes from our operation
it's in like SLA it's a standard we have
and we try to improve our vertical
positive based on that no yeah
understand it
so let's start let's talk about modeling
our base model is something like that we
have the same as Network and as you may
know in Simon's networks the encoder or
the models here are similar they share
the same ways and the ways are updated
uh no this are the same models that's
the thing I want to say
and we can encode many features in
encoder for example we can use title and
description as we said there are text we
can use images we can use Fields
location and category and also for
classification headphere we can use that
product we can use cosine similarity we
can use one or multiple dense layers and
usually here in the UR we use one or
multiple density layers because we want
to add other features there and we
cannot exactly
uh I would say use that product that
product or custom multi uh directly uh
yeah that's it and
let's go to it so the first version that
we worked on it was uh we want text only
and we were only you know feeding text
to our model text and some of these
features basic features
title and description and City and
category were fit to the encoder and
encoding were came out the
encoder uh it was it has the structure
of our encoder first encoder it's a
multi-layer by lstm and you know uh
first before this we were using fastics
and you know it was real it was uh
robust and you know really
finite production but after a while we
couldn't get the the results that we
want from fasting so we tried to use
bile STM
we have some skip connections and layer
normalizations these two have uh no we
this structure was finalized during some
tasks so we found out that using stick
connections and layer normalizations can
help our model improve the metrics we
have attention with here it is with
context layer yeah which is pretty
awesome and you know the the base you
know application for us is as awaited
meaning you know
usually if you have worked with wireless
team models you can you know we have for
example
a hundred uh Dimension Vector of
embedding and we have a batch of you
know
text and each text has many words so at
the end we want to have the same size
features for each text so before this we
know what we was what we were doing was
an average
pooling but after using attention with
context layer I know there were pretty
no good results that we get actually for
example uh in one fourth of the time
that was real that was needed to train
the model without this layer
uh we could train it right now so that
was pretty awesome and we used it every
time we have a subjects the such tasks
also we have some embedding layers for
our category categorical features and we
were using one one hot encoding before
our other for example encodings but
after a while we did a lot of
experiments and the best way that we
could get results with using emptying
layers and we started to use that and
right now we are not using that much of
other encoding
methods and at the end we can't get all
the features that we have and that's the
output of our encoder
so the ROC you see that we get was 0.83
which is pretty low and we were
disappointed because
uh that's not a standard for our you
know production
the problem was that it only captures
semantic information from text you know
we have two texts we digest them digest
them through biolistium and we have two
semantics but
they are only semantics and we saw a lot
of samples that you know the semantics
were not maybe that much similar but the
words were similar so you know they
appear
similar not they were not how to say uh
meaning usually similar they were the
words were similar and that was the
reason that they were
duplicated so that was the one of the
problems the other problem was that we
have a lot of out of vocab words for
example as I said Zack the horse we
don't have Zach in our vocab but it's
really important for us because you know
if two ads are talking about the same
rare word so there's a probability that
they are you know similar but we
couldn't capture that using this method
and also images were not handled we had
a lot of samples that our operation has
detected this duplicate ads using images
and our model had no access to images so
uh it could really do some mistakes and
also our numbers were not handled
properly again when we have numbers in a
text our wireless Sim cannot digest that
properly so we have two ads as we said
they have different numbers but it's not
digested in bile STM and a model cannot
learn anything from that
so uh
for our version two we tried to
create some handcraft features
and
these features were mostly about
appearance of the appearance of text
for example this is our version 2 model
we have a module here which calculates
some comparison features and calcated
with the embeddings in this layer before
the classification head and
and the first three things that we added
was levenation ratio mean hash score and
common numbers
so uh
Livingston rescue and Main hash the uh
there these are two methods that are
used to uh how to say yeah score the
similarity between two texts uh Min hash
is already used in many
services in dur and it's
yeah it's it performs good it performs
moderately good but you know still it's
not the best way but
it can give us a lot of information
about the two texts being similar in
their appearance and we did this and we
get
about two or three percent uh
Improvement in the rocauc it was a
little but it was better than anything
so uh the other problem was that we were
feeding embeddings to the dense layer
but model can't
compare this to ads you know we have uh
embedding is a feature post one and we
have embeddings of post 2 but our model
cannot you know exactly compare them we
could use multiple multi-layer
multi-layer multi-dense layer or we
could simply add diff of this embeddings
so here we added the difference or
subtractive embeddings here and
it was pretty awesome no we got like
eight percent uh Improvement in Roc AUC
and for us it was a really good lesson
because uh our structure is basically
something like that we have a bile STM
encoder and we do all of our tasks using
that but the problem was that we never
thought about using different stuff
embeddings because in our previous tasks
we hadn't that this kind of uh
challenges again this simple feature
helped us improve it improve our metric
significantly and again it was our V3
which was 92.95
and so we think about what's the next
step and we wanted to handle images
the first thing that we wanted to use
was P hash for images P hash or
perceptual hash is an uh way to encode a
two nothing could two hash images and
features in the image are used to
generate fingerprints I stand really
simple method to generate a hash for
this images but they are comparable and
they are moderately you know again good
in production they have the issue with
them is that they have a lot of false
positive but uh if they are not in
charge of doing taking actions if a
model using pH is not in charge of
taking actions uh but helping reviewers
you know our operation to do something
they are pretty awesome they help us
find similar ads we have an elastic
Service uh which is you know maintained
easily using these images and we get a
lot of
how to say help from this method
so we wanted to use it in our model uh
we added three features to our
comparison stats first does add one has
image or not that does add 2 has image
or not and the size of common image
hashes that they have for example we
calculate image hashes and we compare
how many of them are similar and that's
that's it simply
and we get about two percent
Improvement on that and one factor one
thing that I should say is
uh I use this pH images from uh you know
database we have a dump of images a dump
of hash images and it's not it has not
come a complete coverage it has like 60
coverage so in the training we had only
hashes for 60 of images and
using only 60 percent of images we did
we get this Improvement and in the we
are hoping in the production it will go
much more up so uh here it was our V4 we
did we add images
and we wanted uh to do some other things
right
so uh there was nothing that we can do
we can do about our uh deep learning
methods we tried Transformers but
actually uh it didn't fit in our GPU
memory so yeah we forgot about that uh
later then we got some new gpus but we
couldn't do that or at the moment
so we get we went to get some more
features
so the uh it's the extract era we try to
extract any kind of features from our
post we were looking at samples
and you know trying to find out how and
a human can detect that are these two as
similar or Not So based on that we
wanted to accept features more and more
it's the list of features that we are
extracting and we can see level National
scores mean hash scores for titles for
description for the whole text again the
common numbers the number of common
numbers
the number uh if the post has image the
number of common image hashes this are
the same price are they uh what's the
price difference between them
uh do they have the price the length of
uh what's the the length of text and
also one thing that we did was to we
splitted the words in our text and we
had the back of word actually and we get
the length of intersection of for
example titles how many times how many
words in titles are common
how many words are overly in both Union
of titles or descriptions or the whole
text again uh difference of posts one
add one
from add to you know
words of ad1 subtract a WhatsApp add two
something like that
and we did uh add all these features and
the final result was
Roc ACF 9591 and it was uh it was a
really good metric for us it was a
little bit even higher than our
production standards and the point was
that we did all of this in like two days
so it was the end of okr and we had to
get the metrics you know get the how the
key objectives uh done and yeah it
really saved us
it is the tensorboard of uh the
experiments we did here is the first one
and
again the first one was on text only we
uh what was that
I don't remember it
yeah yeah compare some features so we
added comparison features a little bit
better the best difference that we got
was after adding positives and after
that we added images and a little more
uh the other metric features that we add
and this is the final retrain that we
did for
our production
uh
so after that we want we start we think
we thought excuse me about the what's
next and what we are going to do first
of all we did some experiments about
images really simple we extracted some
features using mobilenet V3 small and we
indexed all these features for about 2
million images in a dense Vector
database search called milvus and we got
pretty awesome results you know uh we
for example the query was a picture of
this room and other pictures of this
room were returned in a like among two
million two million images and they know
this uh this shows us that using uh any
print a pre-trained model even mobile
that can help us a lot so we want to use
deep learning methods to generate a
image image features instead of P hash
also as we said we have a lot of
features here
that
yeah we have a lot of features here uh
they vary based on the the categories so
we don't have any structure for them but
there are methods that we can use them
to generate our
embedding
and this is the two things that we want
to work on them later and that's
my type thank you
[Applause]
yeah thank you for the talk uh it was
like really really interesting topic I
have two questions I mean one one is
more not more not of a question but uh
some idea
um yeah yeah now you can hear it sorry
yeah I think for the P hash maybe you
have some kind of compression mechanism
on your website that is when you're
uploading when user is uploading the
image it is getting compressed and then
maybe some some color shifts are
happening and then the P hash is
misbehaving
is it the case maybe
I'm not sure actually no it's a really
good uh especially but I'm not sure I'm
not sure if we do a comparison on you
know we and during the submit of ads I'm
not sure that do we do any comparison or
not but it's a really good thing to you
know we haven't checked that yeah
and then the other one is uh yeah of
course one can go with neural networks
and trying to like identify the objects
and segment them Etc but uh maybe a
simple color analysis can help because
the example for example that you should
have shown were some CPUs I would guess
or and they were
like they were shot from two different
directions
aspects
um and I guess like yeah like this one
like for example it's obvious that both
of them are matching in one thing which
is amount of green huh so if you go to
the uh this four-dimensional uh Vector
which will be the RGB plus the alpha
Channel okay here there will not be
Alpha Channel but anyway
um maybe I guess that could give a good
feature uh that's again that's really
awesome we should talk about this later
but the problem I know not the problem
the thing is that
uh right now we haven't worked that much
on any images and we have some
infrastructure problems with actually
using images because right now if I want
you know that's two million images that
I talked about actually I waited I
traveled our our own website for two
days so I can get two million images we
have some kind of this we have this kind
of in the info infrastructure problems
but as you know we are how to say the
solving these problems we are moving
forward to use any kind of image methods
but right now really I don't have any
information on that because but I really
appreciate your you know question or tip
thank you
uh thanks for talk uh uh I've got some
questions couple of fun I'll just like
trying to quickly ask uh the first one
is about the uh selecting positive and
negative pairs uh how you are selecting
them uh so yeah that's a pretty good
question because uh it's not easy and I
I was uh hoping to put in a slides but I
didn't actually so we as I said we have
operation and reviewers actually review
some parts of ads and when they review
us we showed them uh users other ads and
they can select that for example this
submitted ad is duplicated with another
you know submitted ad in the past so
here we have some labels that these two
posts are similar and for negatives we
could simply uh how to say
uh select another post from that person
that is not duplicated with that also
it's a problem we have because when
someone is uh trying to somehow somehow
post-duplicated ads we only capture one
of them you know so we say this post is
similar with this one and not we don't
check it with all the other posts from
that user but for our negative uh class
generating we use this one with another
for example post from that user that is
not duplicated with it but we have seen
a lot of samples that it's they are
actually duplicate yeah but we have no
way to uh find them right now
thanks for answer and what about the
test sets and the size test set and the
size and are you like updating the all
the procedure during your time because
you get you are getting a new
advertisements
I didn't uh are you updating it uh in a
while when you are getting a new ad ads
oh yeah and what about the size of the
test uh comparing to that the size of
the
at our training uh data set was about 1
million rows and our test sizes were
about 200 or 300 300 and that's the size
that usually works good for us and right
now no it's not training with new
address ads but we are working on a
pipeline to retrain our models in using
airflow and
nothing like that but right now you know
that's the issue that we have and yeah
thanks okay
thank you yeah uh so you mentioned
you're doing pairwise comparisons right
are you doing this across all 500k ads
uh so we don't have 500k ads we have 500
rows of prediction you know we have add
one and add two in each row so we have 1
million add one at two and it's not like
a global search each ad being compared
with all ads it's the Glo it's the
global method that we are doing it's
another project in this project we only
are comparing two
uh posts in each time
yeah but you also mentioned the spam
possibility of the global I guess
variant yeah so that
oh you're only talking about the look
from within one same user okay so do you
have any plans to go into Global so yeah
we have right now we have two elastic
Services which use mean hash Vortex and
P hash for images and they are you know
doing pretty good right now
but they have the issue with them is
their false positive you know ratio and
it's really you know somehow
I'm sad about it you know yeah okay but
right now it's in use it's our old
Service
uh and
uh yeah okay thank you uh one more
question about the P hash so uh the P
hash as you described basically
describes the objects in the image
not exactly you know P hash is like that
it do it does some kind of normalization
on image I'm not sure about that but it
how to say it makes the algorithm
tolerant from color shifting and things
like that so it's coming the car some
kind of normalizations and then it's
converted to a grayscale image and then
the average uh how to say average value
of pixels is calculated and it's by and
his pixel is compared to that average so
it's if it's more we have a one we have
one and if it's less if we have zero so
we have uh a sequence of one and zeros
and we can change that you know to any
uh ask key code and that's the hash
function we have and the you know uh
somehow it can yeah it can tolerate some
kind of the Distortion or distractions
on images and
right that makes sense actually I guess
my question uh stand also from like the
global if you were to do that because
then
the question will be if two separate
people are selling the same car for
example similar car yeah and obviously
the images will be similar even if
they're taken in different places so uh
the point with that is that we don't use
P hash to find similar images we use it
to find exactly similar or images that
have been a little bit edited or
distracted not distracted or for example
the light the color has shifted but
where the source was the same yeah yeah
got it okay make sense okay thank you
Opera
that's what we're playing production of
the inside average
per pixel
yeah I guess I'm not very familiar with
actually as you said that there are some
things you're thinking about this this
task exactly
so as we said the definition is
you know uh two ads referring to the
same real world entity or service that's
not true because we have real estate
category and in real estate category
there is a real estate which is posted
by many
agencies and they are all referring to
the same entity but we are located there
with that because we have no other
choice and no the problem is a little
bit really
still not uh known for ourselves we are
somehow there are a lot of regulators
from the government and you know the
problem is
at the moment
welcome
so thank you thank you for your
attention and time